so like another thing i guess uh that
you've been doing a lot recently is the
whole touring thing right yeah and uh as
someone who well as we're about to do
our very first tour like i want to know
as like
the the upperclassman like oh you know
the experienced one of tours like is the
senpai yeah the senpai of tours
is is there uh like any i guess like how
how different is it to like say you know
a regular convention or like really like
anything
um it's
so much better than regular content
it's like because like well this is
great because you actually have people
to like talk to yeah yeah yeah and joke
around with but when you're on your own
and you're recording a let's play and
it's like am i funny nope
and then you're just waiting for the
camera to laugh back and it doesn't like
when i went on tour i came back and i
was miserable because i was like i don't
know how to make videos anymore
i'm just by myself and nothing i'm
saying is funny
and i think some of that still lingers
around today but it's such a
fun electric energy and i was doing them
like every day and going out to a show
and seeing so many parts of the world
and again food culture such a massive
part
the best part of tour is everything
between your show because i i had a
really good tour family and everyone was
very mature and no
like
there was no like egos anywhere and
everyone was just so nice and i got to
know them so well man the fact that you
call it a family another team just says
like like they say their tour team this
they say
[Laughter]
because you just spend everyone's like
sleeping on the bus and you all kind of
like you're in such close proximity to
each other right if any if any ego is
there you'll know it immediately right
and everyone will get on each other's
nerves but we just have so much fun
going to restaurants and like oh this is
the biggest restaurant in this city
let's go there and yeah we would hang
out and just drink after the shows or go
to a place like a day early we went to
florida and i got to see like universal
and
harry potter land there awesome awesome
just like most of my best memories are
probably from tour
what's like the wildest location that
you remember from like any of your tours
where it's like i want to go back and do
a show there or like i want to go back
there to like experience you know what i
experienced during you know pre or post
show yeah the the weirdest one i think
was new orleans which sorry meowlins
which wasn't selling well initially and
then they were like oh they're a musical
town like they'll show up on the day and
they'll buy tickets at the door right
and then i got there and they didn't so
half the theater was empty it was like
daylight out i could see everybody and
it was like people were yelling at each
other in the crowd at each other
during the show yeah being like you're
great somebody else being like shut the
[ __ ] up he's doing a show be like no you
shut the [ __ ] up
and i was like
i'm probably remembering it far more
like hyperbolic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was like
new orleans is such a weird time because
there's a place called the french
quarter i think and that was like like
all the old timey buildings and like
what you think new orleans looks like
right that area of the world
and it was like right after mardi gras
right
out like still celebrating that right
then it was just like it was almost like
a line in the sand and then suddenly
it's just metropolis
right so it was like going from old to
new immediately and all these people out
in the streets all having fun and there
was like a death museum there and we had
like crawfish and then i had snails for
the first time there and i was like it
was all these like experiences back to
back where i was right i'm not wait
pause what the hell is a death museum
where you go and like look at stuff
about like dead bodies and pieces of
like
not just the cemetery
no you get to see them
it's like a cemetery with windows
at the end you join the museum
it's just like a lot of stuff about like
the history of like death and like
medical culture and how they discover
stuff pretty sure the history of death
goes all the way to the start of
humanity
you can go all the way to the end
you know this this guy isaac death
discovered death and humanity just was
never the same again
he brought it upon everything
but that was a weird experience so it
was just a lot of like crazy [ __ ]
happening but then the i think the
coolest one was probably florida because
i got to do it in universal so i was
like wow like the hard rock cafe in
universal
right so i kept hearing like we're doing
the hard rock cafe and i was like those
are a big deal and then we were like
walking around universal and i was like
is the hard rock i'm doing like bigger
than this they're like that is the one
you're doing oh wow so you actually have
to like go into like the start of
universal to see it wow so many people
outside of it i think there was
something about it like it was the first
one or it was the biggest one in the
world like the hard rock right and then
we got like a private tour around it and
got to see like the upper area where
like paul mccartney stuff was like oh my
god
elvis stuff was like lying around
i was like okay that that's pretty cool
that sounds awesome
doing it and like the floor design of
that one was like a perfect like
like semi-circle and like i was able to
talk to everyone perfectly acoustics
were great yeah
the show slapped harder than it did in
most places
what did you do in the shows
i i did a mix of like stand-up with like
small snippets of gameplay in it so
that's right it was like a story about
my life done in a stand-up comedy way
where i would tell stories of my past
with like punchlines and everything
right but then it was like broken up
into three acts where i would have like
act one would be like my childhood and
here's where i grew up and everything
about that and then i played a modded
pokemon blue because that was the first
game i remember getting that i loved
right but the game the characters in it
like we set it up that you fought your
rival you had to fight six pokemon but
all six were named after like
like
like hard things in your life like fear
right that's cool and then the last one
was called rent
so we'd bring someone up on stage to
play it and then give them a chance to
like be a youtuber for like
20 minutes and then we move on to like
my teenage years and that was like when
i was like depressed and lived in a
cabin in the woods and was miserable and
kind of like just sort of like relate to
the audience and then the last one was
we played shadow of the colossus for
that one because i discovered that game
during that period right and then
someone came up and played that and then
adulthood was all about youtube and
where i went from there and how i
uplifted myself out of that and then we
played happy wheels on stage because
of course it's the most hyped game to
play live ever yeah right um but the
whole point of the show was to kind of
like relate the story of my life
entertaining-wise but to show them like
here's where i came from here's what i
did nothing is special i'm nobody yeah
here i am like doing it yeah how do you
make sure a show doesn't suck
i don't know
[ __ ] because we were hoping you'd tell
us about that
yeah you do do you write the show and
then you're like
[ __ ] it's not funny how do i make this
do you call up screenwriters
help me out bro while i call up uber
drivers in another i did it with real
good touring was like brent and aaron
those guys oh yeah yeah we're doing it
as well yeah so i i like brought out the
structure of it and they were like so
can you perform it for us and i did
practice shows to like 400 people in
like chicago and stuff and i did it and
i was like okay it's a show finally
like i never i never wrote out the jokes
properly i kind of just improv i had
like
like pillars to hint right kind of like
improv
yeah yeah yeah and then as the show
progressed i got better and better at it
and like trimmed the fat a little yeah
but it'll work because you guys know
each other so well you've been around
each other so long and you you bounce
like the same humor off each other so
hopefully maybe yeah you're right
how much like how much planning went
into like i guess not like the actual
like planning the logistics but like the
content of the tour
or the show narrative like yeah how long
how long does that take to like i think
for me it was like four months wow but i
i kind of knew what i wanted going into
it like i i had the idea to do because
burnham had released make happy at the
time right especially before insight and
i was like i want to do something like
that where it's like i always wanted to
try stand up anyway i didn't want to get
up and do what i always do but kind of a
little bit to like pander to the
audience with the games and stuff right
um but i wanted it to make sense in it
but the whole point was that i wanted to
do something fun but have like a message
at the end of it right right right um
and the final line of the show was like
go out and be the heroes of your own
story and like empower people to like do
the thing because everyone looks at this
stuff and they're like how did you do it
who do you know they like got you here
and like pewdiepie shout out and all
this stuff and right they think that
like these specific steps need to happen
right
i grew up in a town of 600 people and
knew nothing about the world
and i [ __ ] up tons of times along the
way and i was miserable and depressed
and hated myself and failed college and
then i was like
i still got up and like talked to people
on the stage yeah
like anybody can do it really yeah yeah
yeah yeah you make it sound a lot easier
it's a different type of show you don't
have to get up and have that specific
true church yeah yeah i mean you sound
like it was it sounds like an amazing
show with an amazing amount of
preparation and content that's going
into it you know you wanted to do yeah
yeah and i'm saying listening i'm
sitting here listening being like guys
um so he set the standard but you know
don't uh don't expect
i feel like i'm just a good bullshitter
i feel like i can get up and like talk
is not youtubers
i feel like i can like talk myself out
of any scenario so right i feel like i i
really enjoy life stuff and i enjoy a
lot more than
like scripted stuff doesn't really play
that well with me
um do you enjoy live streaming much no
that's so odd so you enjoy live stuff
but not like because i can't hear them
by live you mean like the feedback yeah
yeah and it's like you're in the space
and everyone's there for a specific
energy and if like we had a thing at the
start i was like put away your phones
you've seen me through a screen enough
like yeah now it's not the time to do
that that's what's gonna happen to
connor after outsole this is gonna try
and go back in the livestream if you're
like it's not the same
when i when i don't hear the pogs in
like the crowd where's the laugh yeah
you're off track dude
maybe maybe i'll go live number this is
boring
where's the feed i want to see just have
a [ __ ] sound deck where you can
play a laugh every now and then yeah
did you oh sorry it is more fun to do it
live and i feel like
because the show wouldn't translate to a
video well
we did the documentary and everything of
it but we still pulled out so much of
the show from it because i'm like none
of these jokes land if you're not there
of course and everyone's there to giggle
and everyone's there it's like anything
you say will make them laugh and i feel
like
nothing's like taken out of context
nothing is weird about it no one like
takes something and then brings it
somewhere else yeah and i feel like live
streaming is a lot of that where i'm
like yeah i could i could say something
and you could take it out of context and
put it somewhere else and
seeing people show up i'm such a people
pleaser so if somebody says i hate this
and it's one out of like a thousand yeah
yeah i'll still see it and it'll like
ruin my whole mood
so i i just i empathize with people way
too easily and if someone's not having a
good time i'm like it's my fault i
[ __ ] it up so i'm like why am i alive
why did i go live if people aren't
enjoying themselves did you get many
hecklers or anything like that you had
to deal with live
um not like bad hecklers right just
people who are enthusiastic who treated
me like a panel at a convention yeah
yeah yeah and i like lost my trail of
thought and i [ __ ] up one of the jokes
one night and said like the punchline
way too early
um how do you recover from that on stage
though yeah i didn't i just moved on it
was awful i like i like froze and i had
maybe if you do your live show you'll
have this experience because other
people i've talked to have had it where
you go on i i've done the show like like
30 times at this point and then at some
point i was like saying the show and i
like drifted out of my body and i was
like what if i [ __ ] this up right now
and i was like i could say anything i
could say the most horrific [ __ ] ever
that would ruin everything
and then i was like wait i'm not even
paying attention to what i'm saying and
my mouth was just like saying all of the
jokes right and i was like i came back
into my body and i was like i've never
had that experience before wow wow
some therapist is like yeah you have a
condition
come come see me my oldest
well that was so bizarre how your brain
just like takes over and just works
through yeah yeah yeah which i guess
you'd probably get doing live streams
yeah i guess so yeah thinking about
dinner and everyone's in chat like
you're just making jokes though yeah you
can definitely auto pilot it after a
while i mean sometimes i do on this
podcast you know not even with a live
audience sometimes i'm just like my
mouth is like moving right now but i
don't know what point i'm trying to make
i'm just saying [ __ ] but in the back of
my mind i'm like god i gotta take a [ __ ]
do you have adhd by any chance yes i do
yes but i i actually only got recently
diagnosed actually like two months ago
hell yeah high five
i wish i could join in this flex yeah i
can't either i'm just fascinated to know
how many people who do this job have
adhd because i'm convinced that's like
yeah i think it's a lot yeah every
livestream right now has adhd yeah
yeah i think it's impossible to be a
successful streamer if you don't i don't
know about that
to be honest like it's because it's
you know because it's so much stimuli
right
yeah and there's so much multitasking
yeah i guess even like at the beginning
it just felt so overwhelming you know
like you have like you you want to play
the game you want to do with whatever
activity but then you have to have like
a second like like a third eye to keep
like keep an eye on the chat and
everything like that it's like
it's just do it yeah then and then it
becomes second nature yeah like i
remember when you started when you start
off it's like oh
yeah i've said this to these guys but i
i enjoy i don't really enjoy gaming if
if i'm not doing it on stream i just
feel like unless i see those like funny
little emotes popping up in the corner
of my eye i'm like some in my brain
there's a horror for content i think i
maybe i am i think i am a [ __ ] for
content i think i mean there's nothing
wrong with it yeah if i don't see that w
get me up in the morning something about
seeing that spanish guy laughing you
know that just makes me feel so happy
i'm like i made a joke and people laugh
even though it wasn't funny but yeah god
these paid actors are great
what you have is called a parasocial
relationship
maybe i'm parasocial yeah i'm like guys
please turn off
my jokes yeah it's like something to
like making your own schedule i think
adhd people relate to
yeah definitely because like that's why
that's why to me like i could never be
like a full-time streamer i think
because you know with a stream you know
sometimes
you you always feel the pressure to
stream like certain hours you know at
least like prof like real professional
streamers where with youtube
professional streaming yeah
yeah
well but like with youtube my like my
like productivity is not like a linear
curve you know so i'll have like certain
days certain weeks where i'm just like
on it and then certain months where just
like
nothing happens and i don't know what to
do about it and it just like it goes up
and down so that's one big difference
between i think youtube and twitch
streaming that i enjoy i mean you
uploaded every day
yeah with adhd yeah you basically had a
stream of schedule on youtube
yeah
i mean i i have done the streaming thing
for a while we did the server like years
ago all right the among us crew and i
was streaming like eight hours some days
and like staying up until six am to play
it and yeah but after that i don't know
it just made me anxious to go live
yeah i feel like i can make something
more entertaining when it's
paced around editing right but if it's
me i'm like
i don't i just find myself boring you
think there's like too much down time
between like the highlights i guess yeah
i don't know maybe maybe it's just like
a background kind of brain thing going
on right right right i don't know if
just the feeling of having to like
please people live just kind of got to
me yeah i can imagine like because i i i
i guess like i can relate because when
you feel like you do have to like always
be on it and always like be entertaining
it's just so training you know
whereas uh you know with i guess like
with the let's play you can take a break
and you just like okay this part's gonna
be edited out no pressure but when it's
live you constantly feel like you have
eyes watching you yeah plus if i stream
like you said there's a certain amount
of hours like if you stream less than
two hours everyone's like go away
but it just got in the way of other work
like there's other things i want to do
like my youtube would suffer for it and
if i'm not uploading those streams then
what's the point yeah yeah
i'm a much better youtuber than i am a
streamer right right it's not the same
skill set at all yeah despite what
people think